[Music]
[Applause]
okay
woj is back all right um so the the
very important question i ask is is
there a deal that could be made that
might change
a bigger picture here with these uh
these teams come playoff time
you know i listen i don't there's not
a star star out in this marketplace
this trade deadline but i think there's
players who can impact contenders
uh i think the two teams toronto with
kyle lowry and
orlando you know again we talked about
aaron gordon but i think toronto really
is the team
that may dictate this deadline because
kyle lowry and norman powell you know
are two uh you know two good players
that they have and
uh certainly i think if kyle lowry ends
up in a philly
or a miami you know that's certainly i
don't know if
all of a sudden brooklyn thinks hey you
know we're still not the best team in
the east
um but but that can be impactful and
it's gonna be guys like lonzo ball
in new orleans and um you know victor
oladipo
in houston those are all players
available
and and you know who who who all may
very well move before thursday
what do the lakers do with a.d down and
lebron out
if anything well they've wanted to get
certainly more size they may not be able
to do it
in the trade market the buyout market
might be the place where
obviously the lakers could improve
without having to give anything up
because
um you know they may if you're going to
make a trade
you know you want to be able to improve
and you can't always do that when you're
giving
something up so andre drummond in
cleveland if he
ends up getting a buyout if he's not
moved at the trade deadline which i
think it's unlikely because of his
contract that
he gets into the buyout market he's
certainly somebody who they
are focused on and want to bring in
there he'd become their starting center
and so that that's going to be impactful
you're going to see a lot of guys
in guys who don't get traded in that
buyout market and you saw the clippers
create another spot
to be able to add a player in the buyout
market they have two roster spots
brooklyn's going to continue to be
active
there and um you know so i think
for the lakers though uh listen they
just need to get a.d and lebron healthy
and
you know that they're not going to fear
in the first round having to go on the
road in a series that
they know they can beat anybody if
they're healthy and and so i think
playoff position for them
is less important they just have to get
their two their two best players back
healthy and i mean just imagine if
you're this if you're the jazz
or you're the sons and you know you have
just this tremendous season you're a two
seat or a three seater the one seat
and all of a sudden you show up in the
playoffs in game one and there's a
healthy lebron in a.d
you know dribbling into the building
it's it's not ideal
yeah i was wondering about that could
this be a good thing
for the lakers from the standpoint of
now lebron is forced to rest whereas it
felt like he was hell-bent on resting
because he wanted to shoot
show the rest of the league he doesn't
do load management and he wants to win
another mvp
well you know the high ankle sprain
listen that's that's a tough injury and
it can linger
and so i i don't know if it's a good
thing i think though for the lakers
you know their timelines can't change
their timeline certainly can't change
with a d because lebron's out they can't
and they won't
rush him back but you can they listen
they can lose a lot
of ground in the west and you don't want
to fall uh
it's going to be a climb in the
postseason uh
however they look at it i mean they're
not they're they're going to be a team
that's probably going to have to go on
the road
in the first round and and we'll see how
listen and this
there'll be fans in buildings it may not
be
what typically it's like to go on the
road in the postseason that may not be
buildings that are full but there'll be
some capacity and i think that softens
the blow of having to go
on the road in the post season but yeah
i think for lebron he's just always
shown an
incredible capacity uh to heal to play
through injury and to just be able to
come back quicker than others
can but with this one this is going to
be a few weeks
kyrie leaves for three games um
do we know what's going on i know he
said it's personal but
is this something that will continue
this season
no th this um the next
this was a absence that they're fully on
board with and is just sort of the
normal
sort of family thing they said family
matters
there's no there's no backstory on this
of hey we're not
they knew what it was and and um it's
not an issue
can lamello ball win the rookie of the
year
if he's done for the rest of the season
it's a good question
you know has he played enough games i
think anthony edwards is
he's been so good in minnesota and
i don't know how all the things people
take into consideration when they vote
i think certainly lamelo improved that
team that team played
you know they were in the playoff chase
largely or you know him and gordon
hayward
were in that top eight in the gordon
hayward in that top eight in the east
uh but edwards has played so well over
the last few weeks
um i think that he's you know listen he
could finish strong
um and steal it but but lamelo i think
the kind of rookie year he had in the
kind of
just revelation he was uh in the league
and for that franchise i i think it'll
probably
still be close i i don't think it's out
of the question he can win it but i
think edwards
has come on strong enough that that he's
gonna probably have a case to be made
just because of
how much more hill played by the time
people are voting
what would you tell anybody who thinks
there's a chance or thought there was a
chance brad stevens would
leave the celtics for the indiana
hoosiers john
yeah it's just you know you talk to
coaches who've coached in both levels
and there's nobody who would rather be
in college basketball than the nba that
that even now listen there are assistant
coaches in the nba who become college
candidates largely because they're not
sure if the nba head coaching is in
their future or they could go back to
maybe they've been a head coach and
you know a couple of the guys
interviewing for the university utah job
are
nba assistants but anybody who's in the
nba
will only go back to college if they're
forced to if they're not welcome
in the nba anymore and brad stevens no
matter how much money indiana offers
them
listen if brad stevens somehow left the
celtics if someday he gets
fired in boston i i think he's going to
be a long time he's not getting fired
he'll he'll he'll be a head coach
somewhere else billy donovan
left oklahoma city it never dawned on
billy donovan
unless billy donovan could have any
college job he wanted somebody would
fire their coach to hire billy donovan
in college
never dawned he was in him he's an nba
coach now he goes to chicago he would
have had plenty of other offers
brad stevens will be an nba head coach
um
as long as he wants to be um it's just
uh it's just not something anybody would
choose
to do and you know brad stevens in
indiana i know in indiana they wanted to
believe he'd come back
it's just not an appealing uh compared
to the nba it's just not an appealing uh
lifestyle it's not an appeal it's not an
appealing um
the recruiting the portal all the things
that have changed in college basketball
uh constantly having to retool that
roster every year
um people would prefer to be the nba
i'm trying to you know make out what
steve kerr
is bringing up he was on a podcast and
he talked about
and i'm paraphrasing here and that's
dangerous but he was talking about
you know the enjoyment of a team that
won 15 games and coaching them as
opposed to that last year when durant
was there
durant then commented saying it's
hilarious that he would think that but
i i like how much acrimony or drama was
there
that we really didn't know about with
the warriors that
kerr would say you know i get to go back
to just
teaching coaching or you know these uh
players in the nba even though we're
losing
yeah dan i didn't go back and listen to
that podcast so i don't know the context
of what he was saying
um so without knowing exactly the
context of
there was a broader point i saw what
steve said in this news conference last
night that it was
taken completely out of context it was a
difficult year i think it was a
difficult year for
kevin durant for steve kerr i think
there was
a lot of tension around that team and um
but whether it was more enjoyable to
coach a 15-win team i i don't know if
that's what steve said again i didn't
listen
to the whole thing um but but i do think
it was pretty well documented that
you know that was not the strongest
relationship
um within the organization but
i mean that's kind of true of a lot of
teams and a lot of players and coaches
and
at the end of the day you're judged on
the results they had incredible results
with durant and steve kerr together and
um
why did it go bad though like you you
i don't know it felt like draymond green
was onto something early where he knew
that kevin durant was going to be
leaving
and wasn't you know one of the guys but
i mean you had something there i don't
know how sustainable it was going to be
but
when did it go wrong in golden state
i listen i think that just kevin went
there
at a time in his career where the
warriors allowed him
to to to win a championship to win
finals
mvp he built sort of his off court
business in northern california and then
he was ready for something else he
wanted to have a team that was his
he wanted to come east and brooklyn
was attractive to him and he wanted to
play with kyrie irving
and he got the chance to do that i just
think i
i just think it's a different time in
the league where
all of us would look and say well why
wouldn't you just want to stay together
why wouldn't you want to just keep
winning with that group
but that's not the league anymore and
you
you have to maximize these window of
times when you have these teams together
because not just not just in golden
state but whether it was in miami
um or or anywhere else if it's the
brooklyn nets now how long
does that group want to continue to play
together if they win a title or two
titles
um that's just the reality of the league
i think the warriors generally maximize
that window they might have won a title
in the last year if not
for the injuries and but toronto beat
them so
i just think it's not just a golden
state
question i think it's it's a large
broader question
for the whole league and it's it's a
league of of
constant movement and there's not always
great staying power in any situation and
that's
that's the league now uh i know
things are going to get busy for you roj
we appreciate you joining us as always
and uh thank
you thank you again that's adrian
wojcinerowski espn senior nba
insider host of the woj podcast you can
catch woj on espn and abc's
nba countdown